Luke is with us Luke's in Greenville
South Carolina hi Luke how are you good
how about yourself better than I deserve
what's up well I'm going on my third
year of college at Anderson University
and I have recently gotten engaged yay
we we met our our freshman year in
college she's from Concord North
Carolina and she will uh she'll graduate
with probably a little bit of debt not
exactly sure how much she'll probably
have less than I will I'm wrong I'm on
high ball it probably maybe we've talked
about it
probably about 15,000 I'm thinking I
might uh maybe $60,000 of the four years
which is not bad I never actually
intended on going to college I had a my
senior year I had a job set up I was
going to go in the CNC machining and
things like that but kind of long story
short I'm very big in some music I love
music and I feel like that I mean I
noticed the column that God is filling
my life and I've decided to chase it
doors have opened up and it SAT and a PT
scores wasn't high enough to even get me
into Greenville tech much less a
four-year university but God had opened
up the doors and and provided the money
for me to even go to a four-year
university so I'm there I'm getting a
music degree and so I played gigs
about every weekend and I'm a workaholic
I mean I do I do landscape type stuff
I've been doing that ever since song can
I help you no but I'm trying to figure
out how we can save and save money and I
we took at your your financial fish
University class and and talking about
just really throwing our money on debt
and so we're trying to we're trying to
figure out what is the way that we can
save our money and be able to have
something to maybe put down on it on a
down payment get out of debt
okay first step is get out of debt you
went through that you went through the
class you set yet their idea we didn't
tell you to save up and buy a house
while you had eighty five thousand
seventy five thousand dollars of student
loan debt
no sir okay then don't okay so in the
next two years we just start filling
this on on all the debt that we have
just we we graduate let's say let's say
we do we do I don't think it'll happen
but let's say we do get it we're
debt-free and in two years once we
graduate now we got now we need to to
buy a house or something but we have
being that we threw all our money down
down on that we are debt-free but like
where's that where we get that $10,000
or whatever to put down on a down
payment or something like that you know
like where do you go then
okay well let's time to think this
through for a second right you said you
have two years of school left yes sir
and when are you're planning on getting
married oh we like to get married like
after we graduate Oh in two years yes
sir okay so she has $15,000 and that you
have $60,000 we don't have anything
until we're married
exactly okay but let me just let's talk
about you for a second let's pretend
that because you work like an animal
because you're self-admitted
hard-working guy that you paid off
$60,000 worth of debt in two years which
is what she was described yeah but you
have no money if you rented an apartment
for the first year of marriage and both
of you are working and you're married by
then she would be debt-free too easily
if you can pay off 60 she can pay off 15
I'm not sure that's gonna happen but
let's just use that because that's the
scenario you laid out if you can pay off
60 in two years why couldn't you save 30
in one year that's the same rate okay so
one year later you'd have $30,000 which
would be your emergency fund plus your
down payment
yeah and you would be debt-free all
right move into your night moving in the
house yeah move into your new house and
your new marriage doesn't have financial
stress on it then okay the number one
cause of divorce in North America days
money fights and money problems
it's why encouraging couples not to buy
a home until they're debt-free it's okay
to rent for a couple years it's not a
sin in your case is probably not a
couple it might be it might be you don't
quite get all the debt paid off in
then you get married you got a little
bit of yours left and we got to clean
that up and then we save up our
emergency fund and then we save up or
down payment that might take two years
after college oh so what so what when
you move in a house with no house
payment I mean with no payments except
the house payment no payments in the
world except that house payment and you
have your emergency fund in place plus
your down payment the house will be a
blessing instead of a curse when you
move in a house with two car payments
student loan debt a MasterCard a
Discover card an American Express bill
you know they all move in your spare
bedroom and haunt you at night and they
will they will screw up your life so
you're gonna get a house either way but
you're either gonna get it right or
you're going to get wrong and so that's
what I'm telling you is just take your
time and let's do this the proper way
the proper way